- Let's start with
the Super Bowl.
It was noticed,
afterwords, after the game
that Tom Brady and Robert
Kraft, the team owner,
had an embrace on the field
and there was a lot of
conjecture over whether,
you know, Brady and Kraft
were kissing on the lips.
People thought that
was a little strange.
- They look like they were
about to, they both went into a
like, kind of say
something at the same time,
and I believe that they have,
for sure, kissed on the lips.
At some point.
And that's just,
you know, that's
like a long term
male friendship,
I'm not even gonna
fault him for that.
I'm just like,
where was Papa John?
You know what I mean?
You win the Super Bowl,
you're looking around for Papa
and I don't know if it's
because of the scandal recently,
but Papa John's not there,
and I think when you see
someone as successful
as Tom Brady,
almost kiss Robert Kraft
on the mouth in front of
millions of people, you've
got to blame Gisele.
- Oo.
- You know what I mean,
Gisele's not taking care
of business, you know.
If your husband needs a kiss
you better give it to him.
Or else he's going to Kraft.
And it's just like, no
matter how hot someone is,
no matter how many
millions of dollars
she makes as a supermodel,
someone's sick of her
and it's her husband.
- Mm when I was googling
this to see the clip,
cause you know, I
hadn't watched it,
I wasn't watching TV at
the time, there was also-
- You love to talk
about that as if like,
you not doing your job well
is something to brag about.
- There's also a meme out
there, or a kind of a picture,
which it turns out
is photoshopped,
but snoops.com had to do
a study of whether Brady
and Belichick kissed on the lips
after the Super Bowl
too, cause someone
kind of combined
a couple pictures-
- Is snoops.com different
from snopes.com?
- I don't know, I don't know.
- Is it like snoops website
of conspiracy theories?
- That would be an
awesome website.
Cause I don't know
if you remember,
there's kind of been a
controversy over the years
that Brady, on his reality show,
you know, kisses
his kids on the lips
and people just thought
that was strange
and then there's been
Super Bowls where
Tom Brady and his dad, you
know, kind of kissed on the lips
and they're just like a
family kiss on the lips,
that's the family,
way they do things.
And they say that's normal
and lots of families do that.
- What's your point?
- I don't know, that's
surprising to me,
all of that that I just
said is surprising to me.
- I think love is
love, I'm all for it.
That's like the one thing
I can't fault Brady for.
You know, is it a form
of cheating on his wife?
Yes.
Has he cheated in every
aspect of the game?
Including pliability.
I think pliability is cheating.
I think-
(laughter)
I think that these
were non-kisses,
I think it just looked,
like from the camera angle,
it looks like kisses,
they save it for the shows.
You know what I mean,
all that champagne.
You're gonna kiss in the shower.
It's a fact.
Are you telling me no?
- I mean, I didn't, a lot
of people are down there
in the locker room
knowing, you would think
that would come out-
- How many people-
- Robert Kraft has a serious
girlfriend, you know,
I think there'd be a
problem for everybody.
- Still it's Super Bowl night,
53 guys on each roster,
53 guys on the Patriot's
roster plus trainers,
plus owners,
someone's kissing in the shower.
(laughter)
It's statistics.
In fact, if there's one
good thing that came out of
the Super Bowl, besides
the first male cheerleader,
congratulations
Los Angeles Rams,
to perform the
Super Bowl would be
whoever kissed in the showers.
I think maybe that's why
I'm so mad this year,
because of the Los Angeles Rams,
because I live in Los Angeles.
Everyone around LA has
just been head down.
- Yeah (laughter)
- Trying to figure
out what's going on.
It is-
- Its a dower mood around
the city right now,
people having a hard
time recovering.
- Can we please just
move on to the story that
I can get into, that I
can sink my teeth into.
- Liam Neeson got into a
little hot water this week
in an interview promoting
his upcoming movie.
He said, when looking for
inspiration for the role,
for the sort of rage
that he needed to feel
he remembered back, decades
ago, when a friend of his
was raped.
And when that
happened, decades ago,
he said for weeks
he would go around on walks
looking for
any black bastard, and that's
using quotes, his quotes,
to come out of a pub and have
a go at him about something
so that he could kill them.
- Yeah, he wanted to,
he would walk around
black neighborhoods,
predominately African
neighborhoods,
hoping that someone
would step to him
so that he could kill
the man as revenge
for his friend's rape.
And listen, a lot of people are
calling him racist for this-
- Yeah!
- He came out
today and clarified
that he was like, I
was kind of admitting
my racism, and then like,
after walking around
for a couple of weeks
with this in my head,
I realized I'm wrong,
this is crazy, he
shouldn't have said it,
but I'll say this-
- He said he was
walking around with,
like a bat, essentially,
like a shiv.
- What do you call
it, it's a causic?
- A coosh, a cosh-
- It was something that I
didn't understand what it was.
- A Cosh.
- The Irish, and the Irish are
not known for their racism,
so this was, this
really stood out,
that Liam Neeson would
say something like this.
But I remember
just after college,
this is probably right
after you'd left Greg,
one of my friends was raped
by a half Pilipino
half Italian man
and for, I would
say, six months,
every night I would
just walk around
with a can of mace and
a cigarette lighter,
trying to find anyone who was
half Italian half Pilipino.
And it got to the point
at the end of six months
that I would just ask people
if they were part
Italian and Pilipino,
and hope that someone
would answer me.
And the first person who
answers me would have gotten
a coosh right across the face,
but it a, it never happened.
I just love-
- What is, how do you ask that?
- Hmm?
- How do you ask,
how did you ask that?
- It's exactly the same as it
is in english, surprisingly.
The Pilipino language
is a lazy language,
they pretty much
just took english
and just used that,
for the most part.
I just think it's like really
funny to be promoting a movie
where you drive a snow
plow and kill people,
that you would ever
let this be brought up.
But he brought it
up, no one was like,
hey, did you ever, has any of
your friends ever been raped?
And if so, who did it
and how did you react?
He brought this up
during a press tour
for a movie that,
I mean, unless,
the only way this
could have been funnier
is if it'd been
an animated movie.
(laughter)
That he went into this for.
Listen, Liam Neeson's a great
guy, everyone loves him.
- Is he?
- Yes.
- How do we know
he's a great guy?
- Because you can't be around
this business for this long
without horrible
stories coming out
and remember the time
he was on ESPN live?
And didn't know what
the hell they were
talking about for five minutes?
That was amazing.
Do you remember this Erica?
- I don't.
- Oh my god, the ask him
about like Tim Tebow,
he's like we should start over.
Like, we're live, what do
you think about Tim Tebow
and he's like, he's
might as well just be
speaking French to me right now,
and they just, there's no
question they can ask him,
I think he only knows soccer,
and Irish soccer at that.
- I mean, but the thing
is, okay he said it,
you're right, he
did initially say,
you know, it taught him
a lesson, basically,
after four to five
times of doing this,
he realized like, what
the fuck are you doing,
like you shouldn't
think like this.
But it's insane that
he thought that,
it's insane that
in the first place
and I even wondered, like,
is there any chance he's
just making up this story,
to like, be like a
cool actorly story
about motivation and
then he found himself,
like, really trapped in a corner
that he couldn't get out of,
cause he's a crazy person.
- That's possible, and he also,
I mean he was in his twenty's,
early twenty's at the time,
when you're like stupid
and make mistakes,
very racist mistakes, like,
I'm not even going to get
into what pulled in Atlanta,
but when you're in your
twenties, you know,
you don't get a pass, but it's
a little more understanding,
it wasn't like he was like-
- No, no.
- So I was promoting
Love Actually and
I decided to walk around
looking for black people.
- No, no, you don't
get a pass on that,
that's like the people that
are giving the pass on,
you know, the group of
kids that, you know,
were going after the Native
American at that rally,
I forget what that, you know,
what the name of those kids are.
I mean, he was in his twenty's,
you should not be in
twenty's walking around
with like a stick, just
wanting to beat up some,
and kill a black person.
It wasn't like he was
looking for the specific guy
who raped his friend, he
was just looking for anyone.
- Yeah, you don't get a pass,
but if you make it
to your seventy's and
you tell the story,
it's not like oh, this
guy should be fired,
you know what I mean.
Like if those kids make it
to seventy and they're like,
you know I did a
lot of great things
but one time I was
at this rally and
I got in a Native
American's face, like,
I agree with you
100%, but I think,
when you're, he's
like late seventy's.
- But he's still making
like action movies
about killing people
with snow plows.
- Still?
He just made the one.
I forgive him and I'm going
to see the snow plow movie.